it's not easy to bag an Academy Award
they only come around once a year there
are only around 28 categories and let's
face it they're the Oscars the pinnacle
of awards ceremonies so how do you
actually get your hands on one of those
famous statuettes well first of all you
need to be nominated the Academy full
name the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences has got more than 7,000
members and they're all film industry
professionals but not everyone nominates
for everything if you want an Oscar nom
you've got to impress your peers because
at this stage it's actors who vote on
acting awards directors for directors
editors for editors etc but everyone
gets to nominate for the coveted Best
Picture prize the Academy and their
auditors then use a complicated
weighting system to narrow the field to
five nominees in each category once
you've secured that nomination then it's
not just your fellow professionals you
need to well as all members get to vote
for all the prizes so if you see a
nominated actor suddenly turning up at
every events an award show you can be
pretty sure that they're canvassing for
votes and if they press enough flesh it
might just be enough to put them ahead
of their competitors oh and if you
really want to win it really helps if
you're a white man in all four acting
categories plus directing and
screenwriting
only 37 people from ethnic minorities
have ever won an Oscar and while
obviously half the acting winners have
to be women when you look at all the
other categories the disparities stark
for every woman who's won an award for
screenwriting there were 12 male winners
and in 90 years only one woman has ever
won for directing Kathryn Bigelow for
The Hurt Locker in 2010
so that's how you win but who's been
most successful three films share the
most nominations of all time
Titanic All About Eve and lala land each
got 14 nods but Titanic did the best
actually winning 11 the other two movies
won 6 each Lola land almost got 7 in
that famous mix-up when it was
accidentally announced as the winner
before it was revealed there had been a
mistake
awkward some of the biggest acting
winners are Ingrid Bergman Walter
Brennan Daniel day-lewis Jack Nicholson
and Meryl Streep who've all got three
Oscars each and speaking of Meryl Streep
she's the most nominated performer ever
Meryl Streep Meryl Streep in Meryl
Streep
Meryl Streep and Meryl Streep in into
the woods notching up 21 nods between
1979 and 2018 but even Merrill's
achievements pale in comparison for the
great composer John Williams he's been
up for 50 prizes winning five of them
but when it comes to the performers
there really is one big winner
it's Katharine Hepburn who won four
acting awards between 1934 and 1982 for
the film's morning glory guess who's
coming to dinner
the lion in winter and on Golden Pond
those who haven't been so fortunate
include actor Peter O'Toole who was
nominated eight times without a win
Richard Burton and Glenn Close are also
worth some sympathy they've had seven
knots each and no gone but it's sound
engineer Greg keen Russell you should
really feel for he's had 16 nominations
and no win better luck next time Greg
[Music]